it's as hot as a summer's day in the
greenhouses of the Lee Valley but the
Harvest been delayed in the salad bowl
of England so our energy bills went from
circus 700 000 pound per year uh to last
year's energy bills just under three
million maybe 2.9 Million Pound a year
just on gas
they should be picking tomatoes and
peppers here already but heating 22
Acres of Glass House through the coldest
months wasn't viable for Growers
squeezed by higher costs and fixed price
contracts from retailers
we will be looking at obviously Energy
prices to see when we finish the season
so if come
August Energy prices are starting to
rise we'll probably make a decision to
finish the season early again CPI
inflation Rose to 10.4 percent in
February defying expectations of a
steady decline from recent historic
highs
Rising food prices were the biggest
driver increasing 18 and accounting for
fully two percent of total inflation
this increase in inflation has come as a
real surprise to economists and it's
Food For Thought for the bank of England
as it meets to discuss interest rates
I'll have to balance tackling what's
happening in here raising rates to keep
inflation down with the risk of causing
more stress in the financial system the
hospitality industry is feeling it too
the George's part Pub Park Community Hub
but it's squeezed by the competition for
scarce workers that's driving up core
inflation as well as food and energy
prices it's really difficult to find
Reliable
cheerful
he can offer it's simple as that we're
working 24 7 without a wage minimum wage
going up next month for the regulars
it's not just the price of beer going up
I'm a pensioner
and without buying food or anything of
that nature if I don't work my overhead
my outgoings the more than my income
every time I go and do a weekly shop
which I did today
it's
10 pounds 20 pounds whatever more for
just the basic stuff these figures
should end any cozy assumptions about
the path of inflation the campaign
against Rising costs just got more
complicated Paul Kelso Sky News